hi there
welcome to the show are still taking
place in this blank void which fun fact
is actually just a zoomed in picture of
this i voted sticker which is great
unfortunately that sticker is attached
to james woods which is very much
not and obviously we're going to start
with our main story tonight which is
the 2020 election or as it's known for
horses
just another week look at them they've
got no clue
hot idiots this was clearly a very long
very tense week although thankfully it
all felt worth it
due to how it ended cnn projects
joseph r biden jr is elected the 46th
president of the united states winning
the white house
and denying president trump a second
term
yeah that definitely happened
trump isn't going to be president
anymore something i personally learned
from no less than 20 text messages from
my friends and family all saying
it's over which in this situation was
welcome but on any regular day
would terrify the living out of me
as we are taping this on saturday people
across america
are still taking to the streets to
celebrate not just that biden and harris
were elected but you sensed
mainly that a certain someone was about
to get evicted from the white house
[Applause]
hey
you know what that person screaming
donald trump from the back of a moving
scooter
actually sums up pretty nicely how a lot
of people feel right now and i've got to
tell you
it was like that all day here in new
york there was a mood here that can only
be described as a
reverse 911 why because it combined
complete euphoria
and abiding disgust for rudy giuliani
and this time
people were actually dancing on the
rooftops in new jersey it was a really
good day
never forget it is genuinely hard to
overstate the level of relief
that has been flying around parts of
this country especially
at the end of a truly draining week and
tonight we thought it might be worth
mapping out
exactly how we got to this point over
the last seven days because at the start
of this week we all knew that
due to the pandemic this election was
going to be different crucially that it
was going to require
more patience than usual yet for some
reason as soon as tuesday came around
everyone seemed to immediately forget
that because starting that evening
almost
every news channel was overtaken by some
version of a guy playing with a big
screen
while someone comes in to interrupt and
pester them with questions
it was basically the equivalent of
watching the security footage of the
best buy
for four straight days and while news
outlets tried their best to be patient
as things dragged on it was clear they
just couldn't do it
something perhaps best summed up by this
exchange between don
lemon and a philadelphia city
commissioner so how long do you think
it's going to take to count all the
votes commissioner you know it's
interesting
hearing reporters talk about listen
everybody this is going to take some
time
and then the polls close and then it's
why don't you have the results yet
so everyone needs to recalibrate their
expectations
between it's nothing personal
so let me let me ask you this and
speaking of
that was a good answer but are you
talking hours are you talking days
he doesn't know lemon leave the
man alone at that point it would have
been just as productive to ask him
when will penguins learn how to fly or
when is michael keaton going to win an
oscar or
what does the rest of the pringle guy's
body look like is he tall or short does
he have a lot of body hair or is he
completely smooth
when will he be able to tell me what his
nipples look like are you talking hours
or are you talking days what was also
entirely predictable
was how trump was going to react as the
count slowly unfolded because
long before the results were in he took
advantage of the fact that he was ahead
in some states to declare a premature
and completely unfounded victory at 2 30
a.m on wednesday
he delivered this nightmarish speech
from the white house
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
uh no it's not okay it's not okay at all
for a start you can't just threaten to
go to the supreme court when things
aren't going your way
it's the highest court in the land not
the middle school principal's office
and second they weren't finding ballots
they were counting them
and counting and finding are just not
the same thing that's why the movie
finding nemo wasn't called counting nemo
because that
would have been a very different and
much shorter movie one nemo
the end unfortunately that press
conference set the tone for the rest of
the week with the
soon-to-be former president and his camp
doing absolutely everything they could
think of
to subvert this election on wednesday
after the count in michigan
began to favor biden trump tweeted out
we hereby
claim the state of michigan which is
clearly
not how it works calling dibs on states
is not how we elect presidents we use
the electoral college which is at least
three percent less stupid than that the
very same day
the president's personal lawyer and
recent star of the borat movie rudy
giuliani
arrived in pennsylvania to try and stop
them from counting the votes
that were still remaining which stood
out nearly a million
that morning most from heavily
democratic areas and he did so
with this impassioned speech how many
votes do we have to be ahead
400 000 is not enough with 80 plus
percent
counted i think there's only 14 of the
vote to go
do you think we're stupid you think
we're fools
yeah yeah we do yeah
and uh actually this is a bit awkward
now because we had space for a joke here
but that took no time at all so tell you
what instead
let's look at this raccoon-shaped cookie
jar with a raccoon in it did you eat all
the cookies
i bet you did those cookies have gone
from being inside one raccoon
to being inside another what an absolute
delight
anyway giuliani's press conference was
truly unhinged with him throwing around
wild accusations with absolutely no
evidence and perhaps the best response
to it
came from john fetterman pennsylvania's
lieutenant governor
to come in and stand on on on a street
corner in philadelphia say we've won
pennsylvania it's like
you know like like lol i mean like you
know like
it's just bizarre i mean it's it's like
a bad
a bad house of cards episode yeah he's
right
lieutenant governor stonecold is
absolutely right because
this is like house of cards in that it's
full of political intrigue
there's a sexual predator pretending to
be president at the very heart of it and
it's gone on for at least four seasons
too long and for what it's worth
the trump camps protests were
consistently inconsistent in their
messaging primarily because early on
in some states trump looked like he was
ahead while in others
he looked like he was behind which meant
that in michigan where he led early on
his supporters
showed up at a detroit ballot counting
site to chant this
stop the count okay right but in arizona
where trump seemed to be behind his
supporters chanted this
[Music]
now setting aside the absurdity of two
groups on the same side shouting
completely opposite instructions it is
worth taking a minute
on just how weird it is that one of
those instructions is
count the votes because they were
that's exactly what the ballot counters
were doing it'd be like a dad
chanting at his teenage son's bedroom
door beats that
meat beat that meat he is he's doing it
you really don't need to cheer him on in
fact all you're doing is making it way
harder for him to finish
and unfortunately the information vacuum
that formed in those three days provided
ample space for trump and his supporters
to just throw
complete around at one point
trump's twitter timeline
looked like this with a whole run of
tweets flagged as
disputed or misleading meanwhile
giuliani was tweeting out this article
and implying
21 000 dead people had voted in
pennsylvania
which they hadn't also rumors were
flying around that trump ballots were
being disqualified in arizona because
sharpies had been used to fill them out
which was false
and eric trump tweeted out a fake video
of ballots in virginia beach
being burned a video that the city
itself had debunked a day before he
tweeted it and that
is really a shame because normally the
trump sons are so good at getting to the
truth you know
like the time that they solved the
mystery of can a beard
actually make someone look more like a
child the answer
turned out to be a resounding yes good
work gumshoes
but conspiracy theorizing ran so rampant
this week
that during a press briefing from a
nevada voting registrar
this happened oh my god
the media is covering up the violent
crime family
on this election the media is covering
it up the blind crime family steal this
election
somebody is covering up we want our
freedom for the world
give us our freedom to abide in your
mind is covering up this election
he's stealing that
where were we what was the last question
okay there is
so much to deal with there there is the
arctic
call displayed by that registrar while
he was being interrupted by a walking
internet comment
then there was that man's shirt
featuring what i assume were his three
favorite things which i'm
legitimately jealous of because now i
want a tank top
with my three favorite things on it
specifically oversight foyer requests
and hamsters and speedos now that
is a shirt but i think my favorite thing
is just how painfully clear it is there
that that guy was expecting to get
dragged away
and was then completely stuck when it
didn't happen the biden crime family
is stealing our freedom the bond crime
family is still really guys nothing
no one's going to escort me out of here
because honestly i was really counting
on someone tossing me in the car and
taking me away i don't
actually have a ride home otherwise all
right
you know i guess i'll walk have a good
day everyone petergate was a 911 or
whatever
and in the midst of all of this the
trump campaign was loudly announcing
that it was filing multiple lawsuits
in multiple states trying to cast a
cloud over the whole process but it is
important to know
just how ridiculous those lawsuits were
and still
are one case in georgia centered on a
poll watcher who left the room
and thought that a stack of 53 ballots
that may or may not have arrived late
might or might not have been counted
while they're away although the poll
watcher could not say for sure because
again
he had left the room that particular
case was dismissed by a judge because
and i quote
the court finds that there is no
evidence meanwhile in michigan the trump
campaign requested the absentee ballots
stop
being counted after and this is key the
counting had essentially been finished
in the state
that suit relied on one poll watcher
having heard a rumor from someone else
that some late ballots were being
counted and when the judge pointed out
that that was
total hearsay the trump campaign's
lawyer tried to wriggle out of it
before being slapped down hard this is a
firsthand
factual statement made by uh
miss conneran and she has
made that statement based on her own
first-hand physical
evidence and knowledge i heard somebody
else say something tell me why that's
not here say come on now
yeah come on now and look i'm no legal
expert but i am pretty sure
it's not a great sign for your case when
a judge gives you the judicial
equivalent of
out of here now one big trump
complaint that he is making a lot right
now so you will probably be hearing it
for the rest of your life
is that the election is illegitimate
because republican poll watchers
weren't given access to the ballot
counting in pennsylvania
he actually tweeted on saturday bad
things happened
which our observers were not allowed to
see which is a
tough charge to make stick because by
the nature of the accusation
you didn't see them but the claim was
actually even more meritless
than it appears which of all networks
fox news
pointed out the trump campaign has said
that they wanted to have their
their poll watchers there and that i
guess they're
being asked to provide evidence for
something that they say they weren't
able to even
participate in or to be able to see and
so that's i think where
they would say that needs to be
rectified if it could be
that's not true it's not true it's just
not true the claim from the trump
campaign
and the president about that is not true
it is false
in fact the lawyers for the trump
campaign last night in federal court
admitted that he's right they admitted
it
specifically the judge asked are people
representing donald j
trump in that room to which the campaign
lawyer said yes
and the judge replied i'm sorry then
what's your problem
making this officially the single
sassiest week
in the history of the judiciary they
must have traded in their gavels for
umbrellas because
these jurists are throwing some shade
and the embarrassing flimsiness of these
fraud claims
starts to make sense when you see just
how desperately
the trump camp was trying to drum them
up take arizona they announced at a
press conference on thursday that they
had
gathered concerns by thousands of people
about voting irregularities which on his
face
sounds dramatic but it's also a little
at odds
with this moment captured just minutes
earlier
hi everyone if anyone has any personal
example of where they've witnessed
election fraud
here in arizona please come see me
i need i need a concrete example i need
someone to talk to
right over there in the corner thank you
okay that is just
pathetic although i do like the idea
that someone who actually witnessed
election fraud
and had proof was waiting until that
glorified block party to tell anyone
about it
yeah i saw a guy in a ski mask pulling
fake ballots out of his kia festival but
it honestly didn't occur to me to tell
anyone about it
until a representative from the law firm
hangover hangover divorce and meat sweat
told me to meet him over there in the
corner i'm so glad i was wandering by
but wait that's not all the trump
campaign also set up
this website and phone number where they
invited people to submit evidence of
voter fraud meaning if you say wanted to
supply them with an incident that you
found suspicious
you could do that you still can actually
you can simply go to this address
and send them whatever evidence you want
there's even an option to add
photographic proof and quick fun fact
here i don't know why i'm even
mentioning this
a political term of art for election
shenanigans is rat
so if you say that happen to have any
access
to images of pennsylvania-based rat
it's frankly your patriotic duty to send
them to the trump campaign
straight away and all these pointless
lawsuits
are clearly going to cost a lot of money
which is probably why the campaign has
spent the last few days
frantically trying to fundraise for them
emailing supporters
in an increasingly aggressive manner
with one message reading
this is your final notice so far you've
ignored
all our emails asking you to join us in
defending the election
you've ignored team trump eric lara
don the vice president and you've even
ignored
the president of the united states and
final notice for what exactly to not
give them money maybe it's the last
chance to go to the official
donald j trump site and buy this dog
leash
featuring a dog who i can only assume
was lobotomized and given rabies
immediately before having this picture
taken also
quick side note about those
solicitations in the fine print
it mentions that rather than funding
lawsuits half of any contribution
will be used to retire debt from trump's
reelection campaign
which is both completely unsurprising
and also not even the worst thing he's
ever asked his supporters to do because
that
would obviously be when he made them
watch him do this dance
which looks like he's milking two cows
at once
and enjoying it sexually very much
indeed
but perhaps the single most pathetic
part of this entire week was that in the
moments before this race was called on
saturday morning
trump tweeted out i won this election by
a lot
all caps exclamation mark and if that
wasn't
a bad enough case of denial this is how
some of his supporters
responded to news of his defeat
[Applause]
[Music]
look i would love to make fun of that
but unfortunately
i have no time for losers but here is
the really
important thing after this absolute year
of a week
the days of counting the misinformation
the desperate pathetic attempts to paint
this process as fraudulent the fact is
trump lost this election he lost
all that which we've grown
accustomed to seeing work
did not work this time and it's not like
trump and his family are gonna stop
they're gonna
carry on drifting and lying like they've
always done but once he's out of the
white house
it's just not gonna have the same effect
anymore it's not gonna directly impact
every american's life and that alone is
fantastic
and look by temperament i'm inclined to
over analyze everything and i can
already feel myself starting to do it
i'm starting to focus on the negatives
here and be cynical about what a biden
presidency could
or is even going to try to achieve but
before we get into
anything negative at all let me just
give us all a quick moment
with no caveats of celebration in fact
let's put 30 seconds on the clock
right now during which time everyone
could just experience
joy in whatever form you want dancing
screaming
banging a frying pan it is really up to
you personally i'm going to do one of my
favorite activities which is
dispensing excellent facts about
octopuses over footage of people
celebrating this election ready
go octopuses are great they have three
hearts blue blood they can taste with
their arms their brains are spread
throughout their body
they can change shape and color they
have beaks they can open bottles they
they remember faces and they hold
grudges one time an octopus escaped a
new zealand aquarium by crawling down a
drainpipe into the ocean
also there was an experiment a few years
back where scientists gave octopuses
ecstasy
and they learned that if octopuses take
ecstasy they'll hang out and party with
other octopuses but if you don't do that
they prefer to keep themselves to
themselves that's from a real study
isn't it great i'm not saying i want a
octopus but you know what i kind
of wanted oh that's it
that's it that's it that was time that
was uncomplicated fun
so given we just did that if you don't
mind i am going to over analyze this
election just a little bit not much
though
mainly because it is still too early to
draw any big conclusions there are
two key things that we know though the
great news is
that this election had record
record-breaking turnout and over 74
million people
chose to kick donald trump out of office
the less good news is
that more than 70 million people voted
for him
and everything he said and stands for
and that is something
that we are going to have to reckon with
for the foreseeable future and i know
that biden has repeatedly said on the
campaign trail that the ugliness trump
represents is simply
not who we are he did it constantly in
moments like this
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america itself
and that's exactly what trump's been
trying to do
from the very beginning dividing america
based on race religion gender
national origin it's wrong it's not who
we are
this is not who we are everybody knows
who donald trump is
let's keep showing them who we are look
that is a
really nice sentiment but dividing
america based on race religion gender
and national origin has frequently been
very much who we are in fact you could
well argue that in the history of
america the one sentence version of
trump's presidency is
he kept showing them who we are so we
cannot
and should not ignore that millions
voted for trump meaning they either
actively supported his bigotry or at the
very least
were comfortable enough with it to vote
for him anyway which
isn't great it's like if your grandma
was dating two old guys both of whom
had fought in world war ii and in the
end she picks pete who seems decent and
works at the library
and you're really happy for it but at
the same time you are wondering
how the she got so far with klaus
because that
doesn't really reflect that well on her
and even in the joy and relief at the
end of this week it does feel worth
remembering
just how scary it felt as it was
unfolding
with trump supporters swarming and
following a boyden harris bus in texas
and
that moment in detroit that we saw
earlier where a largely white crowd
showed up in a city that is 80 black to
shout that they should stop
counting their votes and if you don't
understand how those images rhyme with
history
it might be because you're just not used
to seeing them in color
because the last four years were not
about just one man
and this isn't just about the last four
years and
even that one man is by no means going
away
whatever happens donald trump is the
current
and future leader of the republican
party certainly at least until someone
else comes along with his stamina
charisma and drive putting aside the
wildly divergent definitions we have of
stamina charisma and drive
that get out garden party guest is right
when she said that donald trump is here
to stay
although not in office however hard he
resists going as a biden campaign
spokesperson told the press this week
the united states government is
perfectly capable of escorting
trespassers out of the white house
which is just a nice sentence to hear
and there is going to be time to talk
about what trumpism is going to mean
going forward
just as there's going to be time to talk
about what this week means for the
democratic party which didn't get
everything they hoped for
they lost seats in the house and the
question of whether or not they'll have
a senate majority
is down to two runoff elections in
georgia in january but the
real takeaway of this election might be
that there
is no easy answer to the question of who
we are
a perfect example is this kamala harris
is now going to be vice president the
first woman vice president
the first south asian american vice
president the first
black vice president and the second
black person we've sent to the white
house
in the last 12 years that's incredible
unfortunately we did elect a white
supremacist in between them
and the fact is that all of that
together
is kind of who we are we're the country
that did
all those things and it's important not
to deny that reality
and just a final quick point here
defeating trump
took a lot of work much of it by
activist groups
led by those with the most to lose from
a second trump term
a big factor in the vote in arizona was
indigenous and latino people
coming out for biden and in pennsylvania
michigan and georgia
black voters were absolutely key with
the groups
organizing that vote particularly black
women working relentlessly for years
and in the days and the weeks ahead
there's likely to be a lot of talk
from white people about how black and
brown voters saved
us which just kind of missed the point a
little bit because they weren't so much
voting as a favor for white people so
much as
voting to protect themselves and their
communities from someone trying to do
them active harm
although there are some lessons in some
of that organizing in georgia
stacy abrams along with many others
helped to register
hundreds of thousands of new voters over
the past two years
half of them people of color and turn
them out to the polls
in fact just before the presidential
race was called
she was already tweeting out details
about the january 5th run off for senate
and making sure that people request
their ballots why
because she knows what she's
doing
and if the democrats are smart which
they are not always
they should listen to her and activists
like her going forward
look it is going to be a long road
to dig us out of the place that the last
four years have put us in but that is
why
it might be so important to remember the
moments of triumph
that this week has managed to provide
richie torres and monday jones
became the first gay black men elected
to congress
cory bush a black lives matter activist
is missouri's first black congresswoman
in delaware sarah mcbride became the
country's first openly transgender
state senator multiple counties elected
reform minded prosecutors and sheriffs
florida voted to increase the minimum
wage and
every state that had a marijuana
initiative on the ballot approved it
and most importantly despite his lies
his obstructions
and his depressingly popular racism this
guy
lost do you realize what that
means
one he's sad right now which is great
but also
no more stephen miller at the white
house no more steve mnuchin
hate to see him go love to watch him
walk away
no more helicopter shouting time i'm not
going to miss that
no more mike pence or betsy devos or
jared
no more jared
and there'll be big systemic
institutional problems
we need to talk about in the months and
the years to come and we will
because for some reason this is the life
i've chosen
but for now after what's just happened i
frankly think that we've
all owned the right to put on our masks
go outside
and party like octopuses on
ecstasy